we start with a very unique format a
best of three wild card series featuring
all 16 playoff teams including eight in
the american league we start with the
astros and the twin josh donaldson who
appeared to aggravate his calf injury
they're concerned that he did some
significant damage to it enough that
he's not on the wild card roster this
would be miata's 25th post-season
appearance just his fourth start first
since 2016.
twins have three on the left side of
second base
and a 1-1 line softly to short polanco
makes a shoestring catch in the air for
out number three
and that's the inning cranky making
his 17th career postseason start his
fifth game one start coming with his
fourth different team
right back up the middle there's correa
fires to first for the out what an
opportunity for the twins early here to
make a statement against the astros
and the bases are loaded with one out
and now the batter will be eddie rosario
that one is ripped right at the first
baseman and a huge out as julie guriel
snares it
3-2 jammed him slow roller third bregman
fires snow out at first and a huge play
from alex bregman
as the twins will leave them loaded
the former great shortstop at lsu comes
up with a web gem no score in the second
bases empty one out is guerrilla and the
2-2 swinging a missed he got him on a
slider so burial strikes out first
strikeout for kenta who averaged 11
strikeouts per night
reddick is gone maeda picks up his
second strikeout of the inning second of
the game
[Applause]
fooled him and he knew it strikeout
number three for maeda third in his last
four batters a value type pick who
turned out great here's the pitch
fastball got him strike three upstairs
buxton goes down and that's the first
strikeout for grinke and there's two
away kepler walks again and now cruz and
the 1-0 pitch lined into right field
reddick going back still going that's
over his head and one hops off the wall
kepler around third tony and diaz is
going to send him correa's relay to the
plate is going to be late kepler head
first slide he scores crews rbi double
and it's one nothing twins
but tony diaz sending kepler all the way
from first base sliding that left hand
on the back part of the plate before
maldonado swipe tag proves the rbi
one-nothing twins so his bases loaded
for the astros here in the fourth
with reddick coming to the plate
got him reddick leaves him loaded he
threw it up and maeda barks at himself
as he walks off the mound
i think it's going to be starting
pitching
starting pitching is going to dictate
how the bullpen is going to be used it's
five strikeouts for maeda
and that one's popped up that should be
caught in the infield jeffers out here
comes to no
and cenote puts it away nice job by
maier
is come on relief of grinky and walk the
first two
two two nobody out two on that's in
there strike three buxton gone good
breaking pitch
from valdez the 01
and that's a ground ball softly hit
third base side tough play bregman he
bare hands throws to first in time to
get crew second time today that bregman
has had to come in on a slowly hit ball
and make that bare handed throw to first
and one nothing game is now tyler
duffy's responsibility to keep it that
way again the 2-2 a check swing did he
go he did chases the breaking ball off
the outside corner
jeffers picks it up and tags out correa
anyway for out number two
tyler duffy works with ryan jeffress and
a very dangerous hitter george springer
at the plate
stands tall here's the pitch slider and
that's a base hit up the middle that
should score redick he's around third
he's going to score maldonado tries to
go to third
and they're going to throw him out
busting with the throw to third base
but collecting the rbi single is george
springer it's one a piece as we go to
the stretch
jose altuve chases tyler duffy and now
we will see taylor rogers danny out here
in a lefty lefty matchup first guy he
will face the veteran michael bradley
got him big pitch on that slider and
rogers gets brantley and the 0-1 pitch
is looped to shallow right kepler coming
in coming in he's there to catch it and
rogers works out of it
trember valdez has definitely been the
most valuable player for the oscars
today if he can get through cruz
and he does how about framber valdez
five strikeouts
since coming into the game
and now the astros are in big time
business in the ninth with runners at
first and second on a couple of soft
hit credit got one to hit and he popped
it up playable for gonzalez and he makes
a tough play
and no advancement big out josh reddick
2-0 this ball driven to left field it's
going to hang up and it's caught by
rosario
and no advancement so you can see romo
he is giving up a couple of singles and
now two outs and he's a george springer
that bad away from getting out of it
george and that's at the short stop the
force out dropped and the twins
stay
alive because there was no advance from
the runner at third the bases are loaded
the twins nearly blew it should have
been out of the inning and now you have
altuve
with the bases loaded in a tie game in
the ninth and two down the 3-2
upstairs ball four and the astros take
the lead altuve draws the vases loaded
walk guriel touches home plate it is 2-1
houston it's left-hander caleb thielbarr
and he's in with correa at third
springer at second altuve at first the
batter is brantley
curveball and that is lined into right
center field and down for a base hit
that'll score correa springer comes home
as well on the third goes altuve a
two-run single for michael brantley and
the astros lead is four to one twins
have a chance
on back-to-back singles cenote and
polanco
and now the tying run will come up
and for the time being it's going to be
willian zosta deal and one would think
would have to be him
curveball and that's grounded third base
side backhanded by bregman steps on
third for one throws to first and that
is the ball game the houston astros take
game one in minnesota
winning this afternoon by a final of
four to one